[Music]
okay
so this is the morning report guys
actually get a morning briefing yep
there is something called AAS Nova yeah
second Astronomical Society has a
surface called AAS Nova which you can
just you know Google and it works out
that there are scientists and graduate
full-time scientists and graduate
students who will take their time out
read interesting new papers and give
interesting summaries that so there
there is a morning so - morning digest
so so basically we have a beautiful
community
know I'm dead I'm dead I think that's
really amazing to have a daily briefing
like that because basically it's you and
the president
[Laughter]
so on AAS Nova or SS Nova as we all call
it - there was a recent article
highlighted which was very interesting
to me because Neil as you know I do
research in galaxies and supermassive
black holes that reside in them okay so
there is a study that was just recently
published of a triple lobed radio galaxy
whoa triple pair lobe okay let me
explain yeah I was going to say please
whoa I mean not for me but for our
friend here in the front I'm sure you
know of course you know I know what a
triple low
so a thirty second explanation when you
have a supermassive black hole in the
center of a galaxy and it's a eating
material right okay what it'll happen is
it it generates a tremendous amount of
energy sometimes more energy in one
second than our Sun would in a million
years okay that's called an active
nucleus or in some cases a quasar all
right when this material jets out from
the central black hole it will often
interact with material outside the core
of the galaxy creating these huge
loads of glowing radio emission okay so
it's common to find a
radio galaxy Agean quasar system that
has a single set of lobes okay okay yeah
a pair of loops it is uncommon to find
double lobes alright but this might be
the very first triple lobe system that's
been found and what that means is that
this particular supermassive black hole
system did its thing for some period of
time maybe a hundred million years okay
spit out these big lobes and then
stopped and after some period of time of
quiescence where there is nothing going
on like maybe it was digesting or maybe
there was nothing to eat at that moment
right suddenly a second burst of
consumption happened and new lobes were
formed at a different angle and a
different orientation Wow and then that
stopped right and then now a third for
the nurses room so what may be a more
accurate name would be the bulimic
black hole bulimic galaxy does believe
in galaxies yeah yeah I like this that's
just belching out stuff that it ate and
by the way we are not immune to that
kind of nomenclature that's right so for
example their dwarfism
by the larger galaxies around which they
had previously safely orbited right
alright and we call that galactic
cannibalism oh if that's the actual name
okay laughs it can not only that you
have merging galaxies right and
in one galaxy sort of acquires all the
mass of the other so that's mergers and
acquisitions universe in the universe so
now what's the difference between a
merging galaxies and a galaxy colliding
when a galaxy collides it may or may not
merge a typical collision of a galaxy
takes around a hundred million years to
happen and then depending on how fast so
we do that on a computer and then you
just watch it right 100 million years
goes by yeah ten seconds
so depending on how fast they hit each
other right all right they will either
sort of go out
and then come back in the merge alright
so the speed threshold of two typical
galaxy say two galaxies the size of the
Milky Way okay is about a million miles
an hour if you're going faster than a
million miles an hour relative to one
another you're not likely to murder
right but if you're less if you're like
the half million or a quarter million
miles now relative when what will happen
is that go pass through and then come
together that overall merging process
takes about a billion years ten times
longer than the actual collision process
okay so you wind up with this big huge
dance it looks like a cosmic traffic
accident fact in the old days this
predates Charles those twelve came long
after I came on the scene Charles is a
puppy in this in the old days we had
catalogs of of beautiful spiral galaxies
or a beautiful elliptical galaxies yeah
and then this other category of galaxies
that were just simply disturbed okay and
so and no one knew why why are these
disturbed